all right good boys
this is a this is a spot where I I've
trapped before but I've had problems
finding water if I don't have water I'm
kind of screwed here if I got water I
got a chance and making sets I can punch
through the ice in a couple of different
places see how deep it is if I'm lucky
I'll find the feed pile this is an
essential piece of equipment for a life
for me out here otherwise I'd have to go
out spend hours and hours and hours
opening up a hole just to get water most
important thing is I need to have some
water between the bottom of the ice and
the bottom of the lake you need an area
there where the beavers can swim in and
get caught in your traps that's half the
battle right there now I got to see how
thick the ice is and how deep the water
is
I've got about eight eight nine inches
so it's not ideal but I think it'll work
right here I'm just gonna set a Conibear
I didn't make the hole really big for
doing a lot of snares on this and Connor
Bears are really positive if you if you
nail one you nail them good with a
Conibear have to just take your cats
here see right now I got no safety on it
that trigger goes off the whole thing
goes off on me I think that might work
that's gonna work